when I was 17 and I came to play a game
I was nervous sometimes play against
those fans everybody wants you to score
coach is looking at you it's not really
comfortable situation
a guy my age but slowly you break
through
[Music]
my name is Danielle do I'm 18 years old
I live in her silly off and play
basketball for Maccabi Tel Aviv my cup
is the best club in Israel best Academy
for you to grow up as a player so my
family thought that it's the best place
for me to go I play with where you
experience God that challenge me and
inspire me to keep 14 instead of playing
my best to help the team win the
teammates likes me because I'm bringing
the child's spirit into the team yeah
Dani is definitely the childish one
around here you know he just kind of has
that little brother thing so it's nice I
mean I like to laugh a lot to smile to
have fun that week maybe I'll do some
stupid stuff sometime you know my goal
is to maximize my potential
Jellico really pushes me to be the best
player I can and you need somebody that
can motivate you and show you you a good
player establish first contact there's
the most important thing you must
establish first one there's a domination
and you have all the tools to establish
the first one
I think that I'll need a little bit time
to learn my body and how to play in this
level so you know every player got his
own pace
he needs to be patient keep working hard
that's how I think about it you see
where I end up you forget I mean Danny
you see his highlights you know he's a
top five pick but at the end of day you
have to remember he's a 18 year old kid
who's getting ready to leave home for
the first time you know he has the same
worries that kids have and he knows
it'll be an adjustment but you know once
he gets on the court he kind of turns it
on he becomes all that potential that we
see income he stopped playing when I was
seven grade I missed a lot of thing
maybe I didn't have the normal childhood
but it was all worth it you know I'm
playing basketball the game I love and
and I can take care of my family really
it's the biggest blessing I can get
[Music]